Herschel Walker has a brilliant new idea
by the way in the midst of this hectic
campaign and race to the Finish Line
tomorrow Herschel Walker says hey you
know what
we've got all of these IRS or as he
calls them Ras
ents who are going to be carrying guns
let's get them to stop the men in
women's sports this is an incredible
idea coming from a guy who has very few
ideas let's take a listen to it and
instead of trying to keep them safe
they're putting me into women's sports
and I'm like wait a minute this is how
you can solve this problem get rid of
them eight or seven thousand RSA that's
going to go after all of us and put one
of those IRS agents in the schools to
take care of our kids that's what they
need to be doing instead of going after
us with these IRS agents but yet they
don't know how to spend their money now
they want to spend your money yeah did
you catch that I mean did you did you
understand the idea and instead of
trying to keep them safe they're over
there putting a million in women's sport
so I'm like wait a minute this is how
you can solve this problem get rid of
them 87 000 RSA that's going to go after
all of us and put one of those IRS
agents in the schools to take care of
our kids that's what they need to be
doing instead of going after us with
these IRS agents but yet they don't know
how to spend their money yeah
um now I think that this is obviously
crazy
but it's important to know the truth
about the IRS agent story
the right is framing the hiring of IRS
agents as some kind of dystopian
Crackdown on the people or whatever the
case may be a couple different things
that are important to understand number
one over the next decade 55
000 IRS agents are going to be retiring
so 55 000 of the hiring of the to be
hired agents are over the next decade
and they're just to replace 55 000 that
are retiring that's number one number
two the IRS is understaffed if you
actually want to hold the wealthy
accountable and make sure that they're
actually paying the taxes that they
should be paying and the things we
always say and that many Republicans say
as well
you need them you need staff to do that
you need employees to be able to do that
and so increasing increasing Staffing
Beyond just replacing those retiring
makes sense and then lastly the entire
gun thing okay it's really a red herring
first of all across the entire country
there's 2100 IRS agents from the
criminal investigation side these are
essentially police who carry firearms
Herschel Walker and others want you to
believe that they're going to be arming
random IRS Auditors auditing people
making sixty thousand dollars a year
because they claim too many deductions
okay that's not what this is that's not
what this is and by the way many
agencies have divisions that are law
enforcement and carry guns if you look
at the MTA right the Metropolitan
Transit Authority in New York City or if
you look up in Boston at the MBTA
they all have like some version of their
Transit Police
they carry guns it's not the subway
operator is now armed okay it's really
not a big deal Amtrak Amtrak has police
yes they carry guns it's not a huge
thing now the good news as far as
Georgia goes is that Republicans
are losing a little bit of Hope now we
have just hours until we know the
results everybody should vote I don't
mention this in order to get people to
take any action or not take any action
if you can vote in Georgia you should
vote in Georgia that's it but
Republicans according to a new political
article which we will link to are
feeling increasingly
Grim is the word that's used here about
Herschel Walker's chances let's indeed
hope that that is the case
huge numbers of people report that CBD
has a calming effect that can help with
anxiety stress insomnia and our sponsor
feels is a premium CBD designed to help
you feel your best delivered right to
your door you just place a few drops of
feels under your tongue CBD can also be
a safe method for relieving minor aches
and pains without side effects the thing
to remember about CBD is that finding
the right dose is important and feels
even has experts on call to help you
with that over the phone if you need a
dose of Chill on the go you've got the
feels CBD infused mints and you'll get
fresh breath hard to complain about that
and with a feels monthly membership CBD
is simply a breeze you save money on
every order you can pause or cancel at
any time become a member today and get
50 off your first order with free
shipping when you go to feels.com Pacman
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below